hello everyone welcome to another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here with a new friend David Jennings
who is an author he's an entrepreneur
and we're here to talk about how to
build authority and influence and he's
got a book all about it is going to tell
us about it and you'll cook engine for
us David welcome aboard fantastic thanks
for having me on the call it's a an
early start coming here from the other
side of the world Australia so good to
be able to connect and yeah just excited
to see what direction we're going now
it's four-fifteen on the east coast of
North America here well what time is it
there it's six a.m. ok team I thought I
thought you thought it was I thought it
was a little worse if I was like 415 or
something so that's good that's a start
but it's not that bad I guess that's
pretty good well thank you for waking up
early with us to share some wisdom for
the entrepreneur pleasure so for people
who aren't too familiar with you what
you're all about maybe just like in 30
seconds who's Dave and then let's get
into what your book is all about yeah
I'm a serial entrepreneur he started
lots of different businesses like all
good entrepreneurs probably the last
thing I need is another good idea and
it's all about the focus and probably
over the last couple of years I've
gotten better at really narrowing in
where my strengths are and I found you
know you look for the overlapping
circles in your life and two areas of
mastery to figure out where you should
focus and I'm really strong in marketing
really strong in systems and really
strongly business so I've kind of looked
for that sweet spot and we've set up a
couple of companies based here in
Australia that kind of helped me operate
in those spaces I love it and so today
we're talking about the simple system
for building your brain your sales your
credibility you've got a new book out
right yep authority content just came
out and went live on Amazon a couple of
weeks ago and pretty excited actually we
got Amazon bestseller in quite a few
different categories both in Australia
and in the US so really well received
good reviews and yeah just happy to get
a dumb writing a book is is tough work I
know man I just finished that process
now too so I feel you I feel the pain
but also the joy in like birthday in
this creation
so tell us tell us the contact tells the
thesis of the book what can we learn
from it what's the message for
entrepreneurs yeah so this is really for
business owners or really businessman or
ladies who have ideas that they want to
get out to the world like they might
have a good product or service and they
need help spreading the word about what
it is that they've got and doing using
online as a vehicle to do that is
fantastic but a lot of business owners
they just get caught up in the
day-to-day running of their business
they don't have time to create some
great content to share out on the web or
on social media so the book is a system
and a process that's drawing on one of
my areas of expertise a process for
batching the content creation taking as
much out of the brain of the business
owner and the business owners team
capturing it in one day and then having
that live on the website and also
sharing it out across the web and
creating really great quality content
that captures attention engages an
audience and and builds their trust
that's ultimately what we're looking at
doing it makes it in a simple process
for them so the idea is an entrepreneur
is an authority or at least should be an
authority of what you're doing if you're
getting results you know you should be
an authority in your subject matter and
what you're trying to do is help them
quickly create content to show off that
authority but not have it take up so
much of their time that they just stuck
living on social media instead of
actually running the business so yeah
and this there's a whole lot of criteria
that people look for when they look at a
business owner or a business to
determine whether or not they are
actually on authority and um the
different criteria that people have to
look at it varies from one person to the
next and it can be things like how well
is the website design what sort of body
of work does that business have what
sort of case studies do they have how
easy is it to find their different
contact information how much does it
look like they have great products and
services and they understand their
target audience so there are all of
these different factors that people look
for when they're trying to determine if
someone is an authority or an expert in
their space so this is very much not a
fake
you make it exercise its authority
content is a way to try and tick as many
of those boxes as we can in the least
possible time because we know there are
certain elements that people look for to
go oh yes I have that feeling now that I
can trust this business or hey I know
that this business can deliver on their
promises because when someone makes a
purchase online that's the biggest
hurdle they have to overcome they figure
you know if I'm going to spend my money
to buy this business's product or
service am I going to actually get what
I paid for the result right and yeah
this is about trying to set that up so I
mean it's a model that I I believe in I
built my business you know around me and
sharing my opinions and thoughts
although I had a hard time at the
beginning where I would just share other
people's ideas it start with my website
sharing other people's content whether
it's steve jobs or you know whoever it
is and people started asking about me
like who was i and what are my views and
opinions like well Who am I prefer to
Steve Jobs what do I have to say that
would be relevant when you're learning
from these masters but there's also that
personal element to wear with the
business if they feel like they know and
trust the owner who you know the face
behind it then it really builds a
personal connection we're now people
feel like they know me and they come up
to me and they stopped me and they want
to talk to me and they know about my
wife and my son and all this stuff that
I shared it I go great you know but I
don't know any who you are but it's
great to meet you this is fantastic so
it definitely builds a personal
connection to with the people consuming
the content so that they do like you
trust you know you and a few much more
comfortable buying whatever it is from
you um okay so yeah go ahead well it was
one of those things I think particularly
with a video and one of the reasons we
like to lead with video is content is
that connection video is one of the best
ways in fact it yeah the best way that I
know to duplicate yourself as a business
owner we all know where got we've got
limited time in the day and video is a
great way to capture your ideas and
things and then let someone experienced
who you are in a very leveraged way and
yeah they can watch a couple of episodes
of
your hangouts and stuff like that and
I'll get that feeling like they know you
even before they ever get to meet you in
person so that's definitely part of the
process is having that type of content
that people can consume so by the time
they do pick up the phone and chat with
you or you meet with them in person the
question isn't hey sell me on the idea
on whether or not i should do business
with you but rather okay how do we
actually are we the right fit and how do
we get started so it kind of moves /
people further along that cycle that
buying cycle I'm and I'm talking in
terms of business but you know depending
on how your meeting someone and in what
context it can also pre frame just that
relationship it changes the dynamic a
little bit if someone feels like they
already know you and they've got that
trust and they recognize you as an
authority Authority is a funny word you
have to be a little bit sort of careful
because sometimes people think you know
authority can have good connotations or
bad connotations you know respect my
authority type thing but really for me
authority is about and becoming a
trusted advisor just like a doctor
almost where you look towards a doctor
and oftentimes you'll trust what it is
that they have to say because of all of
the background stuff that they've done
to get to a position where they can call
themselves a doctor have to go through a
lot of study they have to do a lot of
different things that I just hand out
doctorates to anybody and and because
they've gone through that process
there's a certain amount of trust that
usually you'll have before you ever step
foot inside the door of surgery right so
how about going through an example I'm
probably a bad case because I'm already
I'm already doing it a lot and I'm in
the business of kind of being an
authority but I'm thinking about one of
the business diameters is a day in
school so we'll teach salsa you know
local business uh it's I'm not the
day-to-day guy so there's you know
there's a operator who's the head of the
school I'm much more behind the scenes
so you've got this local business you
know it sells dance instruction classes
you've got somebody leading it who who
is an authority on the dance and is very
personable and maybe
let's say you know wants to be an
authority and be more recognized wants
to bring more awareness to the business
but is also very much involved in a
day-to-day running of the business right
like being a being again being an
authority is my business you know for
him being authority isn't his business
but could be a good part of the
marketing plan and I think for a lot of
people watching are kind of in the same
boat where they have their business and
they recognize the value of it so walk
me through so the guy who runs that his
name is Alex you walk me through what
Alex has to do or in your opinion what
you would do with Alex to help him you
know build the brand to help his
authority grow and help the company grow
as well yeah for sure so and the book
goes through this three-step process and
it's a present product and promote so
stage one present is all about batching
that content creation because as you
kind of rightly identified most business
owners are busy they're stuck in the
day-to-day operations they when you talk
them through this idea and marketing
online they intuitively know that yes
it's a good idea to be putting out
content but who's got the time to be
sitting down writing a blog post pumping
out a podcast and making a video that
it's very hard to make that space and
they might just do that you know even
the proactive ones might do it once a
month or something like that so the
first stage really is about how can we
batch that content creation I think it
does need to come from the business
owner or at the very least some staff
within that business because the whole
point is we're trying to elevate the
authority of that particular business
and I think the further that the content
creation gets from the source the
business that the more often than not it
loses the message and we see this all
the time where people go to a Content
writer you know a ghost writer or
something you know someone who doesn't
fully understand the business they write
about the business but they don't really
get the essence of the business and if
you think about what content is content
is that first point of contact that
someone will have with your brand in
your business when they're looking for
you online so you want to make sure that
you step with your best foot forward so
for that first phase you need to really
think about your target audience
and you need to think about what
questions and problems do they have what
are they thinking about just prior to
them making a decision that they want to
go learn to do salsa so when we think
about your target audience and their
online and they're searching on Google
and YouTube would probably be a really
good fit for this because I can imagine
people looking for dance steps and stuff
like that they might just start to look
at some of the different types of dance
and they might go on to youtube to try
and find what's the difference between
swing dancing and rock and roll dancing
insult sir and those sorts of things but
you're probably going to have a little
bit of a better idea than me what what
types of things would someone interested
in dance be going on to google and or
YouTube or whatever and running some
different searches and normally you know
just prior to them making a purchasing
decision or maybe even a little bit
earlier maybe they're just still in that
research mode yeah and and some kind of
long those lines to them thinking the
natural tendency when i first started
work with entrepreneurs on their content
is is everything becomes a sales pitch
so their first content is here's why you
need to join our company and hear that
accuse the biggest reason why we're up
to the best or if you sign up now you
get fifty percent off and it just like
constantly pitch mode as opposed to
actually create an authority content so
yes it can be a little bit about the
school on what you're doing but but more
to your point about the questions you
got your pulling up the book i want to
read and the the definition of authority
content as i've got in the book alright
the definition is authority continents a
bit of a mouthful to unpack it but its
authority content is the act of
consistently creating and distributing
helpful information and stories to gain
the attention engagement and trust for a
clearly defined audience with the
objective of identifying those who will
benefit from your products and services
so to unpack that it's about
consistently creating helpful
information basically to capture
someone's attention and doing it over a
sustained period in time so you start to
get their engagement and build their
trust now it is of a clearly defined
audience and we know that someone who
engages in this
type of content it's almost like they
self select themselves as someone who
would be interested in your products and
services by the very nature of them
wanting to listen to the content so
while there is benefit in yes having
those frequently asked questions where
it might be in a very sales driven type
content that's at some point in the
cycle but even before that let's not
lead with hi my name's David my products
cost six hundred dollars per month to
work with me let's lead with what
problems do you have how can I help
solve them so I thought I jump in there
so sorry to step in there but damn yet I
think you were talking about how it
would relate to the dance studio yeah I
was just seeing the same point i love
the message i think also especially we
can get the entrepreneur themselves to
tell their story why they started it and
why it's important that's how you stand
out versus the big corporate people
write it like if somebody's looking at
your website versus a big company why
would they go with you or a big player
the big plan may have already the brand
and the reputation and you know I'm not
going to get I'm not you know I'm going
to get consistent experience going with
this big company we're going to take a
risk on you well it's the passion it's
the story it's the excitement right you
make me feel something a personal
connection I don't feel too XYZ corp
yeah and understanding what those
differences are and understanding that
hey people do business with people so if
you can get your personal story out
there what will end up happening is
someone will listen to that story who
might be looking at your products and
services and they may or may not but um
find that connection where they got our
he's just like me he got interested in
celsa dancing the same way he started
dabbling with it at school but never
really followed it through didn't become
professional but has loved it his entire
life that's just like me hey he's just
like me you know maybe that's someone
that I want to find out more and for the
person who there is a direct match you
will bond so closely to them for other
people that might not resonate you know
and whether or not they're not your
target audience or they'll still
appreciate the story and wow this is
real and authentic because that's
another big thing about becoming an
authority being real and authentic and
presenting yourself for what you
actually are I think there's something
that draws anybody in when you're real
and authentic it's it's especially on
the online where a lot of people hide
behind their websites and you don't see
that branding that personality so it can
be quite refreshing I remember having
somebody callin on my radio show talking
about he was a gardener and he like cut
people's grasses too and he was having a
hard time competing because the kid down
the street would do it for 15 bucks and
he was trying to charge a lot more and
he said I have something like why what
makes it different for you and he said
he grew up always around outside the
garden with his mom and he treats every
lawn that he goes to like it's his
mother's lot all right and so like I
didn't have that exchange with my mom
you know I'm not the person who goes
outside and I hate cutting the grass and
I don't want to plant flowers or
vegetables you know my wife likes that
but I'm not going to spend any time
doing that so I don't connect with the
story that it's me but I want that guy
cutting my grass like I want him taking
the pride because I'm not getting that
from the kid down the street and so I
would have known that unless he shares
his story it's funny this these little
things like that like when I think about
two of the people at work you know in my
world and when we were looking for a
cleaner and for our house and we got a
few cleaners that came by the person we
ended up hiring she got to the front
door and she took her shoes off she was
the only person who did that and I
thought wow you take enough pride and
thinking about cleaning that you get to
the door and you choose a dirty so you
leave them at the front door wow you're
the type of person that I want to hire
and I'm saying with we were looking for
a child care center and my wife went
around to all of these different child
cares and the one that we ended up going
with she walked into the child care
place and she was holding our son Nate
on like one of those little carry things
and his leg was kind of a little bit
stuck and she came over before she said
hello or anything she said oh you might
want to unhook his leg he looks a little
bit uncomfortable there and that was
kind of like wow you you're really
focusing in on what's important here and
those elements when when you're sort of
in your area of mastery and and those
things can tell
but present themselves so I think that's
we can you know unintentionally capture
that type of information or we can also
intentionally capture it but I think the
key is to yeah really actually
authentically and you'll find those
types of things come out in the content
you create and I love it ok so that's
step one is make the content yeah and
and batch it is really key so the
business owner is busy so the way that I
like to do it is I run these mini
workshops i call them you know before
when you say workshops people imagine
hey i'm sitting down at you know tables
and I've got work books and things like
that and sometimes that makes sense
sometimes it doesn't but it could be
it's really just a way to batch the
content for example we worked with this
cosmetic Institute where we actually
went into their surgery they had a
doctor sit down on one of the chairs and
they had about three or four clients and
patients that came in and this doctor
sat on the entity of the chair and
talked about some of the things
questions that people have about
cosmetic procedures so it's it doesn't
have to be workshop workshop it's it's
really about having one day where you
batch this content creation and you know
you're going to have it's got to be in
front of an audience that gives a little
bit of a different energy it also stops
the business owner retaking over and
over and over I see this all the time
and because we're this video studio and
people sometimes book it out and they
come in and they they might spend half a
day or a whole day in the studio and I
walk out the other side with one or two
videos because it's just them in a room
there retaking it getting it just right
whereas if you do it in front of an
audience bang you've got to do it first
take you keep rolling so you do all the
pre thinking upfront about the type of
content you're going to create you get
some staff in there you get you in there
you might even get a guest expert in
there it doesn't have to be a big fancy
production but it's that positive
constraint it's a line in the sand you
know you've got to be ready on this one
particular day I used to have this
friend yeah he just started being an
entrepreneur and he used to always sleep
in he would never get out of bed on time
so he thought I've got to figure out how
I can do something so he ended up
parking his car out the front of his
house in a clear way zone because he
knew if he didn't get up on
and that would tow his car and it's that
it was a positive constraint that caused
him to act same with the idea of picking
a date and presenting and in one day you
know you will show up if you know that
those people are going to be there and
you probably get 30 or 40 different
videos that can be chopped up into
little segments so that's that stage one
is all about presenting then we kind of
shift to stage two and that's about
turning this into some sort of product
now you have to at this point because
the listeners listening to this and
applying it to their own business they
have to think what type of business have
I got and sometimes you could take that
content and turn it into a digital
product it could be something that lives
on your website you know and you sell it
for a couple of hundred bucks and it can
make a fantastic down sell someone calls
you up about your service and you say
yep this is what I do here's how much I
charge they say look I don't have the
money and you say no worries we've got a
home-study version that you can grab up
on the website and it's a do-it-yourself
it can make a great cross sell or I've
added added value if someone buys your
your service you say hey you also get
this course here and it explains what it
is that we're actually doing now that
that works for some businesses but not
all businesses and give you another
example we worked with a swimming-pool
manufacturer here in Australia and it
wouldn't make sense for them to have the
how to build your own swimming pool home
study course so then we did it a little
bit differently we we made it almost
like a buyer's guide on that first day
we captured a whole bunch of content
around what are the questions that
people ask just prior to making a
swimming pool or buying a swimming pool
and it's things like should I go
fiberglass or concrete how close can I
build a swimming pool to my house and
what do I need to do to maintain a
swinkle how long does it take to build a
swimming pool and we actually took all
of this content that we captured in that
once first stage the present stage and
we turned it into this open resource
guide that we called a buyer's guide
that lives on their website and it had
this central post with the you know the
chronological order in which people ask
these questions and then links through
to specific pages that had a little
video and the transcript underneath that
answer that very specific question so at
this stage 2.2 someone needs to think
about their business does it make more
sense to sell a digital product or you
know have a digital product or is it
becoming an open resource but that's
that kind of stage 2 does that kind of
make sense right and then some of it
could be used for social media as well
your YouTube channel or Instagram or
Facebook perfect and that flows into the
final stage which is the promote stage
now you're sitting on this mountain of
content and as I said right on the start
most business owners they struggle to
create any form of content but now
you're probably sitting on a mountain of
content and you don't even know it you
don't need to drop all of this content
in one go and start sharing it this
could be your content strategy for the
next three or six months because we can
take the videos and we chop them up into
those little segments with him split out
the audios and those audios could get
uploaded to SoundCloud or iTunes and we
can then take the audios and give them
to someone who can transcribe it they
now take the transcriptions we compare
the transcriptions and the blog posts
together sorry transcriptions can get
paired with the videos and become
optimized blog post on your website you
can monitor which bits of content are
performing well and create derivative
works you might you put up a whole bunch
of content and you'll go hey for some
strange reason this video gets 5 X the
number of views or engagement than
anything else and you go okay well I've
hit a little hot pocket here how can I
create more content around this you take
the transcript then you give that to a
ghost writer and say I want you to
polish this up to a nice article you try
and extract the ideas and you turn it
into an infographic you know if you want
to get fancy you can start to pay to
amplify that content you know boosting
that content across social media and
yeah sharing it across social media and
emailing your database it's all about
thinking it where is your target
audience and how can we use this content
tailor it to the platform and then
deploy it on that platform and the good
thing is everything after stage one
stage one the business owner must be
involved in beyond that though this is
that can processes procedures can step
in you can get out sources VA's I mean
this is fantastic work for you know if
you've got offshore talent that takes
content and repurposes it and 11 days
worth of content you might get 200
pieces of content and you can drip out
one or two of these pieces every week or
two and constantly giving you something
fresh and useful and engaging that can
go for your audience and this is how you
can yet have a content strategy that
lasts for a whole year and you stop
becoming that guy who posts one good
post every three months sure it's a
great post but you only do it you know
once every three months you these days
because the market place is so crowded
so noisy you have to be creating good
quality authoritative content
consistently over a long period of time
and there's a lot of benefits that shake
loose from this from traffic to
conversion to building up your authority
positioning but I mean that's gotta ran
through a lot there but that kind of
gives you an overview of the strategy
right so for that for the solo
entrepreneur or even the part time
entrepreneur who wants to play a bigger
game and you listen to this they said
this sounds awesome but also sounds like
a ton of work yeah it is what do you
what do you recommend what would be the
only strategy for companies that have
like no no no rights over that person
what they do what definitely works at
different stages in a business cycle
depending on how it's built so if you're
a startup entrepreneur and you're just
getting going the way that I'd use this
authority content process would be to
document the way that you do what you do
because over time the business owner
wants to bring in more staff surely they
want to get more people to help them out
so you could use authoritative the way
that you deliver your products or
services so one of the very first things
I did in a video production business
that we run is I I ran a workshop that
explained how we create great quality
videos because now I get multiple
different things
not only does that help demonstrate my
value when working with someone because
they can see the actual process but it
also works really well as staff training
as well because now when someone starts
with me I say hey watch this course
first it'll teach you everything that
you need to know about the way that we
do business and and then that also forms
the foundation for us to start to create
some of the documents and processes
around how we systemize business so for
the startup entrepreneur it'll also help
clarify their thought and nothing forces
you more to think about logically what
it is that you're doing then knowing
you're going to have to present it so
it's a great way to really get it out of
your head what it is that you're trying
to do so you can very much work for the
startup entrepreneur it can work for
more established businesses and it is a
lot of work but it's a case of we're
building work that has lifetime value
like we're creating digital assets when
you create some of this content video
content I have a stock market education
background that's kind of where I came
from and I operated in that space and
developed this methodology in that space
and some of the content that I created
in there 15 years ago or actually
probably closer to 10 years ago is still
to this day driving me traffic making me
sales but i have not operated in that
space for years so it business is a
marathon not a sprint and you need to be
in this for the long game and you need
to focus on work that pays for a
lifetime but the work i'm talking about
it you know you're working for a client
and you're getting paid for a service
you swapping time for money and all
entrepreneurs have to do that while
you're getting started up and running I
mean that happens but as you need to
still carve out and devote a little bit
of time into building assets things that
work where you do it once and it will
continue to pay and overtime the
objective is to find more and more time
to spend focusing on building up these
digital assets and working on that part
of the business
and authority content is a great way to
do that it's just a bit more of a
structured process that keeps someone
focused because you know you're online
as sidra hard at the start the last
thing you need is another good idea you
need a focusing on one thing that makes
sense follow it all the way through turn
off a lot of the other noise so you can
start to get that result so for some
people this will really resonate but
there are other people that are just
looking for that magic button that they
can press that's really easy the one
last point I'll make on that is we're
finding now particularly if you think in
terms of Google and the opportunities
for exploiting loopholes now are
shrinking so if you do find a little
loophole in the system where hey I can
do this strategy and it games the system
and I'll get a little bit of traffic
we're finding those last four shorter
and shorter periods of time Google's
getting smarter algorithm is updating a
lot quicker your buyers are getting a
lot more savvy so you're much better off
focusing on things that have a real long
lifetime to pay off rather than
something that gets you a real quick win
right now and because then usually those
quick Queens you just have to keep
reinventing yourself and then doing the
same thing over and over try to look for
that loophole so again probably packed a
bit in their vet yeah a few points I
love it lots of great knowledge there
David thank you for sharing i would say
it also starts with and I would
encourage people watching to have the
mindset that the authority marketing is
really important you have your hang time
for you have to make it important you
know when I hired Alex to take over turn
over and salsa I gave them a list of ten
different ways that he can market the
business whether it's using the media
whether it's critter Markham a product
whether it's doing SEO whether we're
doing advertising and I said one of them
has to be you're going to be the face of
the company you're going to be the face
we're going to do storytelling we're
going to do YouTube videos you're going
to be on snapchat you are going to be an
authority that's that's given and then
pick one or the other nine and that's
the other thing you to focus on because
it's such a great way to build a
business and so for those you guys
watching if you're not sure about /
authority marketing I'd encourage you to
really
test it out try for yourself because it
pays just crazy dividends can perch a
lot of the other ways to grow business
so and it it's one of those things where
intuitive leaf as a business owner if
you think it through it just makes sense
content becomes it's the first contact
point the first engagement that a
prospect or a client will have with you
so we when they're searching online and
they're coming across different
platforms or even if someone makes a
referral they're going to end up at some
point package to website and when
they're there they're going to look at
and what things are they going to look
at to determine whether or not they're
going to do business with you if its
content that's how they're going to get
to know you so you want to make sure
that you come up with a way to be
creating this content that is engaging
and we all know that not everybody is
going to want to do business with you
right now either and if you're not
focusing on still helping those people
who aren't quite ready to make a buying
decision now you're leaving so much
money on the table you wanted when
someone comes to your website and if
they're not quite ready you still want
to give them helpful information and see
what you can do hopefully to trigger
their interest enough that they might
give you their name and email or at the
very least you know you might be able to
remark it to them because they've hit
your website now you can drop a cookie
and you can run ads specific to them
driving them back to content again
demonstrating your authority trying to
capture their attention doing it you
know getting their engagement and then
hopefully you do it over that long
enough period that someone goes this
business isn't a fly-by-night this
business they are excellent at salsa
dancing they care about salsa dancing
they arm assuming that you guys do salsa
no I didn't even ask runs it does it
happen um so yeah they care enough where
yep I can see that passion coming
through and if I ever want to be in a
situation where I want to learn salsa
dancing these guys look pretty good
because they really love what it is that
they do and that's ultimately what we're
trying to create and if you spend your
time focusing on that and I mentioned
video video
is one piece of the puzzle because it
starts with video and I love video
because we can repurpose that video in
so many different ways but just think of
it that you are you're you're focusing
on an activity that helps you duplicate
yourself we're all time poor but if you
can make a video that answers a question
or a point what a fantastic way to make
more time in the day for you now you
don't have to answer that question again
someone calls you up on the phone and
you say are fantastic yep he's the quick
answer to your question but by the way
I've made a video that helps to answer
that in much more detail can I just grab
your name and email and i'll send you a
link to that video what a fantastic way
to you know save yourself some time you
know get them into your marketing funnel
and be really helpful to them as well so
like this type of content gets involved
all the way through your buying cycle
it's yet I'm clearly passionate about
love it i love how it makes a big
difference I really do cool well thank
you guys so much David thank you so much
for all the value for those you're
watching go check out Authority content
the book Authority current amazon on
amazon Authority content also 30 content
com2 right right naw Kham whatever the
Australia thank you hey you hey yeah
just yet this Authority content com uh
David appreciate time and so much value
good luck with the book really
appreciate the novel today probably
watching go check out his book continue
to believe I will see you soon thanks
for that